hey pooch
hey Larry
how are you doing
hey Ray
how are you
hi Lorraine
hey Betty you look beautiful
how's everything
[Music]
what are you showing me Ray
oh your new truck
is that your name
you had to buy another one
yeah
yeah it's okay
I get one putting no more money in there
I get it and I hope that it just go I'll
just go get another truck yeah it won't
break down you need Wheels
we pay
we pay three thousand dollars down
and paying 300 a month
because we get a payoff okay I can help
you with that how far I got him put two
new tires on it hey Timmy
invite Timmy so this is Lauren are they
walking on the road
so this is Lauren who's helped me out
Laura Lauren
Lauren
Lauren this is this is Larry not Lauren
I'm Larry
and this is Betty and that's Lorraine
that's all right that's Ray and Timmy
back to the door
got it and you're Larry yeah okay
my name kind of sounds like Lorraine huh
my name sounds similar to Lorraine
Lorraine and Lauren
how's everything
I know
hey Timmy
what's going on
how are things
uh we were in Knoxville last night Clay
County Leslie County Harlan County
no no we didn't we didn't hit Pikeville
this time
you're going right past it
went to Knoxville as well
[Music]
oh you cleaned up right you give him a
bath
yeah
I watched the tire because the tires
look dirty okay all right well we're
gonna get him haircuts today yeah I
gotta go get a haircut today yeah yeah I
told him that still
or shaving
you're gonna get shaved too
did they shave them when you take them
to get a haircut do they shave them when
it goes for a haircut I'll get it
you're gonna shave off the beard yeah
everybody
you can use it you can use a little
shades
what's going on
is that new
raise pointing the table
yeah from Alabama who's that
it's a metal available who's in Alabama
oh is it your friends from Alabama that
visited you yes yeah she's been writing
me yeah
do you guys like being visited by my
viewer yeah sure nice right yeah they're
nice they're real nice people
fail
that's all buddy ever tonight yeah yeah
you guys are making friends all over the
world oh yeah
yeah that's great yeah
I talked to her a couple days ago I told
her we're coming to visit you guys
having all this attention
been disruptive for your life or is it
okay
has this whole experience of meeting me
and all these videos I put put out has
it made your life better or worse that
might have better that's great it's nice
to hear I would hate to think I'm making
your life worse
there's Kenneth
yeah
that's my brother you ride it you ride
the four four-wheeler I don't ride
I love your laugh right
so what are the dogs names
hey Kenneth hey Mark how are you doing
okay
let me get you in the song here it's too
dark in the shadow
no you're in the shadow this looks much
better
how you been you working
and not a day no but you're still
chopping wood yeah
today
that's great
yep
at least somebody's working here
yeah
thank you
so I'm taking everybody for a haircut
today you want you want to come with
yeah oh look at you you just got one I
think I got one you got a buzz cut yeah
look at that
I didn't got one you don't need anything
you would have waited I don't got one
okay
Timmy's getting a little bit longer over
the years he could use a little cut yeah
Jimmy dude you know what I'm coming so
you know that you're stupid
The Three Stooges yeah he looks a little
bit like uh Curry curly yeah what
happened to your head Timmy you got a
you got a scarf let me see it he won't
see your head let me see your head down
fell on
meatballs
you okay
you guys have to take care of each other
yeah I tried to he's up he's hard
oh we're gonna take him up to Beckley
there's a place in Beckley that that
takes care of men and women it's like
it's like a women's salon as well as a
men's like Barbershop
yeah everything's bacon okay where
in Beckley
what you're talking about yeah that's
where we're going
to wear it back
[Music]
we just checked them out they're they're
ready for you guys
oh they're ready for me they're ready
for everybody
so it's beautiful weather today oh yeah
it's beautiful it's raining this morning
when I woke up yeah I know it's raining
this morning
so you guys told me that Jason is out of
jail Jason is out of jail yeah
I'd love to talk to Jason
thank you Kenneth
yeah he's gonna do it when we come back
from getting haircuts Jason's gonna do
it he'll do a little talk with a little
video with me
doing what
I just I just want to do it like I do
these interviews with people on my on my
YouTube channel oh and Jason is somebody
that I've been in love with for a long
time he's he's he is the perfect
candidate for what I do he's maybe the
perfect person for what I do but he's
never really
Jason and I have never really gotten
along right I don't know so I heard
about it yeah yeah yeah no he went for
his gun last time
so so this time uh
we're gonna
we're gonna do it again
what is that dog licking
Paul he got run over oh Jesus
the dog got run over yeah
oh yeah
he lost his toenail
so how did you guys survive the winner
how'd you survive the winner
yeah he didn't you had a mild winter we
had a mom win
a cold it was nice
yeah
yeah come on are you ready we just had
cold weather
someday it was pretty good some days it
was cold Lorraine when's the last time
you went to get your hair
okay
[Music]
she's camera shy she was talking to me
she was yeah she said pretty
oh yeah she likes she likes women you're
pretty
hey hey
hey I heard them people died down here
and move out right down here oh really
okay
he got a double wide trailer
down there I heard they want to sell it
I don't know how much we'll find out
find out maybe maybe we'll buy your
house
they got conquered all the way around
try to respect down the concrete and the
glass set on concrete the driveway the
concrete what can I they want the same
as Arizona
okay
how much I'm gonna be you know
hmm
so you guys fight once in a while you
guys fight once in a while yeah
so so show me the show me the property
down the street but before I leave show
me that property down the street
right here how far how many houses
the next one
the next house yeah
yeah the next House on the Left okay
I'll take a look I'll take a look you
know I don't know they let you go over
there
you can stay from around
okay
yeah yeah well we'll check it out it's
real pretty big cry
and the big two a double wide hot
trailer I'm sure we could help you out
I'm sure we can make that happen
you know I apologize
yeah you guys could definitely use it I
told Betty I would like be in the living
room because I not to say the crack
where the stop it in the corner you
could see the daylight coming through it
there's pulling loose hmm
God I'll get to where the creek then I'm
so high
and get up in the back of it and pulling
him find that your love
you know the creek water yeah
you you can't keep me outside running
around here and now he's never sitting
down
the creek has never flooded here has it
the creek creek has never flooded here
sometimes
oh
garbage spot there good job really
that's gonna be scary huh it's got to be
scary
when you're living in a trailer and
there's a river going right through your
backyard yeah
I I got yeah get up right
get my gear
5 1999
I'm sorry I'm probably my wife's a
foundation that's what I'm saying how
getting the whole play go down that's
what I'm saying
right now
Lorraine's comfortable yeah yeah he was
saying she sleeps here sometimes you
sleep outside mine
you got me in a truck
and I'm here on the hall
set up you got some comfortable
Furniture here
oh God
Timmy you ready for a haircut
maybe a little shave
yeah you are okay Tammy Timmy he said
you ready for a haircut
roll in half I need to take your fingers
out there yeah it's okay
now you working on the road yeah Bob no
the road the road
you want to come with us
your hair is not out of control
what are you watching Ray
you want me tie your shoe
[Music]
here you hold the camera
you hold the camera I'll tie your shoe
box
[Music]
maybe point that thing at me so people
can see me tying your shoe
can you see me in there
what kind of cameraman you are ready
but your shoe is tied
[Music]
oh you want to try the other one
all right here so hold this hold it down
low
there we go
you can't go out to get your hair cut
without your shoes tied
there you go
thank you Ray
hey
you live in the good life here right
look at you
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's your bed
your knees feeling better
that's good
River dog
how you get out of pretty women working
with you
what's that how you get all these pretty
women looking for you oh yeah you must
be fighting well
I'll tell everybody well okay you got I
pay you guys well too I pay you guys
well too no by me well yeah it's true I
don't I don't everybody thinks that you
took advantage of the GoFundMe money but
you didn't get a dime of it no no
what happened to hell what happened to
Elle
no no assistant not sister she was my
assistant oh not not sister
no it's not my sister
no assistant
right here you going out to eat
you guys ready for a haircut
what time you get you ready
good timing
come on out here and take it
yeah he can't kill you oh what's up
what's up Ray
Kelly
Morgan ain't gonna kill you you're going
to go I know people can see all these
flies there's a hell of a lot of flies
here yeah look
laughs I've never seen so many flies
five
that
Lorraine make yourself at home
what are you saying about the baby
photos
do you have photos of you guys when you
were young
you don't but why you tell me why
I couldn't pick up Burger who burned
them my brother why I don't know why he
just burned all the photos
do you think Jason has some photos no
you guys
oh that's sad
I want to see you guys when you're
little Lauren this is Jason Jason learn
she works with me nice to meet you
how you doing
ugly cow
who drugstore
what Kelly tell you Kyle
you're a store
I told him I tell you
um
right
oh yeah
[Music]
thank you
raise them is now
look at it
what are you showing me
it's nice to see your fridge fully
stocked
you got everything in there let's take a
look
nice
sausages shrimp
is this where you have breakfast
is this where you eat
yeah
Morgan ain't gonna hurt nobody
oh yeah
what other animals
Bears I ain't tell no bear that's good
I'll take one
you've seen bear hey I'll leave it
I'll run down on top of it
I don't say no bird Harley what's the
craziest thing you've seen here what's
the craziest thing you guys have seen
here living here I've seen
no not animals just like craziest thing
with the neighbor with the cops with
anything
maybe the first time that I showed up
with with with my cameras that might
have been the craziest thing I've ever
seen
do you remember that day do you remember
the first time I showed up here
yeah you remember that day I'll never
forget it
that might have been the greatest day of
my life I think
for his haircut he's got a brush in his
hands oh good
all right shall we take you guys into
get a haircut yeah let's do it okay
can you guys all fit there scoot over
me
a little bit of a tight squeeze
where do you guys normally go for a
haircut Betty
I don't
want to get my haircut you don't no
Jason said he cut razor last time oh is
that right
all right
all right another road trip
hey
we'll see in an hour or two
uh
mad
what's your favorite season
you guys like spring summer fall winter
me too
it's beautiful here
summer
your house doesn't get cold in the
winter
I came I keep my heart far
what do you burn I burned wood yeah
yeah how do you think the town of odd
got its name Betty
out of that
it's an unusual name for a town yeah
I'm a Creed
Tommy Creek is yeah
Rodeo
well I'm glad to hear you've made some
friends
through these videos
a lot of praying
it's nice to see yeah it's nice to see
people showing kindness to you guys
you like it to me
it's nice
yeah she said she sent them to me I'll
show them to you
bye
you know
the way
Lauren's a good driver
how many hours did you drive last night
like I got in at like 2 30 in the
morning yeah
that's what Red Bull's for
Betty what would you guys normally do
for dinner
what will you guys know what's a typical
dinner for you guys
already
you what you don't want to go
home you go to Hardee's
you ever cook huh do you ever cook yeah
what do you make
it like what what do you cook well we
took the dollars
spaghetti macaroni and cheese
the only real hot
or what would you ever even cook
do you like to dance yeah
who's the best dancer
I think it's Ray I got a feeling
when there's the right girl
Ray's probably a dancer yeah
this Ray got any new girlfriends no no
didn't take long to answer that
I don't have a girlfriend
even though I have a girlfriend
Timmy's got his mom
look at those two they sleep together
how old is Timmy now
how old are you Timmy
44 44.
number seven
amen
oh
so when when Ray and Timmy got to get a
haircut do they get a shave as well
I want to see Ray with a clean shirt
clean face
still got a good full head of hair yeah
Ray's got great hair
Gray's hair used to be dark right
back when I first met you your hair was
dark right
you guys still going to church
give me lorenia Timmy and Lorraine go to
church yeah
yeah
that's to pay the toll right
you did this before
but
good night
daddy how often does Ray
and Timmy and Lorraine get to go out of
the house like this take a road trip
will
right look at Petco up here well Lauren
Texas
sorry take him out when we go doctor in
the store oh so they get out once in a
while yeah he's gonna let him home
no right you're gonna pay that don't pot
don't pocket that money
hey Ray
now updated her
hey
hey how you doing all right
where do you change any change can you
change back up back up
here he comes here he comes here you go
Ray
all right we're close enough yeah I
don't have exact change okay
that's all right now we have exactly
it's looking straight
it's all good
good job Ray
thank you Betty
I'm gonna put the window up to me
Timmy we're gonna shut the window
[Music]
uh
do you ever dress up for Halloween
you celebrate Christmas
you celebrate Christmas yeah I can't
love Christmas
no tree or anything nope I'm not allowed
to find no more yeah
I fell off the roof
you fell off the roof yeah when was that
a couple years ago really
you hurt yourself
you know where you go
so what about birthdays you get like a
cake or anything
like your birthday
what'd you do for Timmy's birthday
when's Timmy's birthday
April 7th
last week
last week today's the 14th
happy birthday Timmy
happy birthday to me happy birthday
Jamie
when's your birthday
August okay
we made it
you guys ready to get your hair cut
[Applause]
this is Ray what is your name what's
your name my name's Chris hey Chris I'm
Mark this is Ray
and this is this is Timmy
Lorraine
and Betty
hey hey
uh can you do the two guys at the same
time yeah yeah so yeah